how are you how are you feeling right
now because this is the big kickoff of
awards season the Palm Springs
International Film Awards always start
things off and I think with the
incredible performance you've given in
House of Gucci we're about to see a big
run how are you feeling thank you Lauren
it's really really
um extremely humbling I'm very grateful
and I am I'm honored to be here talking
to you about this award today and to
thank all the people that made this
possible there's a huge community of
artists all around the world that worked
so hard during covid to keep art moving
and I'd like to really pay attention to
all those people so Palm Springs
International Film Awards giving you the
icon award how does it feel to be
recognized for House of Gucci with this
award
really a huge honor and I I think about
all the awards that I've won over the
years and the way that I have always
wanted to be an actress and I'm here now
receiving this award and I keep thinking
to myself how grateful that I am that
it's for a character that is a real
person that I chose to play in a
particular way you know I I believe that
sometimes we focus and hone in on single
stories and uh we sort of Herald the
idea of women and Patricia rajani is
somebody that was you know notorious in
Italy and now is much more well known
around the world for this role but there
was a way to tell this story where it
was about a woman using her body and and
manipulation to get what she wanted a
woman that used greed a woman that gave
herself into Scandal and murders for
money
but when I read about her and I did
research about her I realized that
inside of Patricia regiani was the story
of many women and to receive an icon
award for that it is extremely
meaningful to me
um the story of many women should be
told
and you I mean you've done that so many
times over from your music videos to
this now so I just want to thank you for
always telling the stories of women
because it's something you uh you did
from a young age at a time when I don't
think all women are are able to do that
yet you know I don't think I did it on
purpose in a way I think that I'm
starting to realize now in my mid-30s
that I'm looking back on my career my
short career I've really only been known
as an artist for 15 years and five
before that so 20 but um I'm a fairly
Young artist and actually you know I was
fascinated with Marilyn Monroe with
Princess Diana I was fascinated with
Ella Fitzgerald and Judy Garland and
Billie Holiday and Dinah Washington you
know these figures they
they
they created a a generous and
imaginative spirit in me when I was
young and I think also as I endured my
own
experience in life I realized that we're
all connected and it's it's never one
thing a woman's story is not one thing
we all have different stories and now
I'm sitting here thinking okay now I
want to see you play Marilyn Monroe
since you just mentioned her
well I I'm pretty sure there's been a
lot of films made about Marilyn Monroe
and another one coming out soon that I
heard is wonderful
um but you know I I think I'll always
tell the stories of women because I I am
a woman and and being a woman I I have
those stories inside of me to share and
women are powerful and uh women uh are
are vulnerable and and to be vulnerable
and strong at the same time I think is
is it's a truly special thing was you
just said in your short career but
incredibly full career you are now
getting the official icon status I mean
the icon award the words right there
um but was there a moment when you
thought to yourself a moment in your
career when you thought wow I I've
achieved my dreams I've reached a status
that I'd always hoped for that sticks
out in your mind you know I I don't
think I'll ever forget my last
performance of the monster ball when I
was about I think 23 years old and I was
in Mexico City and it rained and all of
this equipment broke and we were so
nervous about uh all of us falling on
the stage while there was water
splashing everywhere and the water was
pouring down on me and and I remember my
microphone was wet and I remember
singing as loud as I could sing I
remember looking at a hundred and fifty
thousand people and
healing all of their hearts feeling all
of their souls and knowing that there
was a community of people that all
believed in one thing which was that we
were all different and that that was
okay and I I think that I felt this way
about life really when I was very young
because of community and because of
people believing believing in each other
um so to me this you know this like idea
of value of being an icon or the status
of being an icon is is less about
um about being the best or the greatest
and it's much more about who are you
connected to and what is the message
behind why you're connected and uh is
there meaning in it and and can that
then become your purpose because I
remember that night in Mexico City I
kissed the center of the stage when I
was done and I knew it was my last show
and I said Thank you to the stage
because that stage supported my feet and
my feet supported my legs and my legs
supported my body and my body supported
my head so that I could sing that night
and so that I could receive the love
from everybody in that room and take
their stories with me I think about that
even with Betty White you know we just
lost her but how her status as an icon
was about her contributions her breaking
down barriers for women her being a game
changer and and you have been that in
such a short time it's so incredible
um this honor does though also put you
in the company of uh not just women's to
men too Michael Douglas Tom Hanks also
Glenn Close and One Missed Meryl Streep
what goes through your mind when you
think that Lady Gaga's name will now be
read in that list when someone gets this
award next year or the year after that
you know uh
all the time I what what goes through my
mind when I hear you say that is how I
wish to bestow upon as many people as
possible that might be watching this
that if you have inside you something
great that you wish to share
there will be somebody to receive it if
you have The Bravery within you and the
courage to keep going I feel very
blessed in my life I feel very blessed
to be in this company and I also feel
very validated as an artist to be in the
company of of these actors is tremendous
and these are very committed actors I've
I've always looked up to do you know
what you want to do next we heard you
might be writing a musical I did speak
about my desire to write a musical
um but I do have something in mind uh
for what's next but I'm I'm not going to
reveal it just yet
um but I I will uh say that uh this was
an absolutely amazing experience I just
feel really blessed that I get to make
what I loved during a time that is so
difficult and I I just like I just want
to ground in that with you Lauren on
this because people watch TV I think at
home and they think I think that some of
us don't that we don't live in the same
world but I I live I live in the same
world as you if you're watching and I
see what's happening and I love you that
dress is giving me some Patricia wedding
dress Vibes I'm just wondering who
you're wearing oh really a little bit
like who are you wearing I'm wearing
Rodarte and I I absolutely love it
um and I was feeling uh I was feeling
more like a fairy Punk today
what are the award season fashion plans
any any outfit with you that we can look
forward to
um my the I my award season fashion
plans will be comfort
because uh comfort's important and I
don't think women need to torture
themselves for fashion I want to show up
and I I want to make people smile that
love watching the award shows and I want
to be there to celebrate all my
colleagues and all the legends that have
come before me now we know that you
consulted another incredible actor
Bradley Cooper before you took this role
what is it about his opinion his Insight
his friendship that are so invaluable to
you
you know Bradley was really the first
filmmaker to believe in me for a
starring role as an actress in a movie
and I will always value his opinion and
when I talk to him about playing this
role you know he was extremely
supportive but he's always very honest
and he's insightful and he's he has like
a clarity about him that is really magic
and it's magic for him uh as an actor
It's Magic from as a filmmaker I think
he's phenomenal in Gilmer del Toro's
nightmare alley uh I I I I wouldn't have
asked anybody else first about this
movie uh you know other than Ridley of
course himself well we want to see that
icon award do you have it and can we
give you an opportunity to thank anybody
who you'd want to thank for it right now
I've always wanted to redefine what it
means to be an icon
and receiving this honor my true dream
would be for you to Envision my legacy
as a mirror reflecting all of you
I think sometimes we focus so much on a
singular icon someone like me that we
forget to seek out icons that are
already all around us icons like your
grandmother your school teacher your
neighbor I even bet some of you have
called your best friend iconic
inspirational icons reflect authentic
community and are built by Community
communities that are connective share
values are not afraid to debate are
generous
the lgbtq plus Community the artistic
Community those who feel unheard or
those who simply align with my vision of
a Kinder and braver World I'd like to
thank you
I know it was you that built our shared
image and shared message into an icon
you're all mirrors reflecting through me
and through each other
thank you to Chairman Harold matzner and
the board of the Palm Springs
International Film Society I'm so
grateful to be receiving the
international icon award for my
performance as Patricio reggiani and
Ridley Scott's house of Gucci
foreign